[Music]  hello  [Music]  brings the total missing in west pine to  five all within 36 hours  who are you  you must never tell a soul  deep in the woods stands alone door  my colony and all of our practices exist  entirely to protect the world from the  awful things beyond that door they worry  that the wrong person could learn about  this door and let all those awful things  go free  gary what's behind the door  nightmares your worst nightmares  [Music]  are you like the terminator  have you seen this girl i've never seen  her natasha this particular girl is a  cold soul killer  you sure she's not around the corner in  your kitchen or in your bedroom  i'm here to help you  ready to hunt a monster  [Music]  is so metal  i'm gonna end this thing  why are you walking like that it's my  power pose i do it before recitals when  i'm nervous oh hell's greatest weakness  empowered dancers i feel so safe  you